la racchetta non posso metta che se c'è
il copyright cali non si può fare che
bene tutti a questo nuovo video di tags
totali a cure eight battle simulator e
come potete vedere da questa queste
riprese incredibili si può fare su
attacco titan può trovare bellissima
star o la volevo dirvi ragazzi che non
solo se si può vedere ma anche
combattere ad esempio io se metto mikasa
qua da sola in mezzo a tutto sto casino
qua è un po una merda proviamoci non
porca [ __ ] cosa succede e cosa fa
gigante colossale non capì di casa di
casa e va bene forti ma vabbè ma è
durata tantissimo c'è un abito
incredibili da sola e vediamo un attimo
scusate i no perché sono curioso di
vedere cosa è successo
ok non vedo neanche non la vedo nemmeno
equa di casa la madonna piane o ritiene
da sola ritiene non è male il gigante
globale che è svenuto lino o e da sola e
cioè la gara è tanta roba da solo la
pazzesca sta roba da gigante messi anche
lì che un casino le stai andando mikasa
occhio che c'è il mare c'è il mare lì
c'è il mare
a meno che non non li puoi buttare tutti
giù che non è un bar brutta tattica
perché bravissima ma è caduta di casa
combattono in mare dove è tornata su
eccola qua è morta mikasa peccato perché
la è durata parecchio io posso anche
mettere gigante colossale questo mentre
tutta sta roba è
provo io prima vedere se riescono a
utilizzare i propri cervelli vai 2
mikasa i due nomi kasami livelli vedi
proprio così mi casali vai contro tutti
quanti e va beh secondo me è un pelo e
non lo so esco lei sono svantaggiati
come giganti sempre forti noi ogni casa
li porta sul mare non ho idea del motivo
qualche roba cosa fanno qua
libè cosa far cosa succede e proprio
come nella new e sono fortissimi mica
saliva insieme qualche roba mi fa un
culo 4 è pazzesca sta roba
mai mi casa non riescono a prenderla
neanche per sbaglio è bellissimo cosa
succede la madonna è volato qualcuno mi
casa ok
ne manca uno lea partita fa tv i tre
bravissima dei motori tutti sono morti
tutti i quadri vai è morto per ogni casa
sta ancora combattendo contro aerea meno
chi è questo gigante l'attacco vice
spaccano tutto gli respinge tutti gli
attacchi pure ci ha fatto è scattato al
suo ormai si stanno picchiando da soli
due giganti di pietro dai centri my mind
sto guardando la scena finché non
finisce in realtà nato sono morti quasi
tutti e manca il gigante con sale e il
gigante messe che hanno già preso a
mazzate la li vai quindi teoricamente
potrebbe essere una buona sito avermi
casa questa e non è male ok brava mikasa
bra amiche cosa vera ma come è quella di
traglia che spara solo ogni tanto a caso
dove mi casa la perdo no hanno vinto per
poi vorrei durata è questa adesso sono
curioso di vedere una cosa non ho
veramente curioso sa già che è l'amica
sa season 4 cioè pensate vediamo bene va
bene secondo me questa volta durano poco
i nostri titani ma fa niente è un po
riassunto della season 4 questa insomma
il gigante con sano muore cioè poco
immortale c'è di qualcuno che si sta
applicando ieri
e lì che ho capito però mi sono anche
l'obiettivo
sono morti tutti tranne il gigante con
psyche accerchiato da 62 mikasa va bene
mi sa che qui è finita ai ragazzi non so
non so quanta vita abbia il colossale ma
quando ha vinto colossale la no e
fortissimi ente allora con detto come ho
detto adesso road race fff va bene va
bene mi sembra un pelo grosso e le
gigante road race vediamo break dance
del road race week altro sia un danno ma
cosa fa ma che modo che tecnica di
attacco e spiega misero drive spiega mi
aiutava stai gabbando per terra non è il
massimo questi cosa stanno facendo
cos'è una sorta di danza moderna ballo
moderno cos'è road races capitano solo
ammazzata e la thai fermo è lì che si
dia botte il gigante corsa è andato a
picchiare gli altri che tanta corto
punto chissenefrega spicchiamo centro di
noi
non ho ancora perso però non so come è
finita così aveva chiesto non è finita
facciamo finta che sia finita lo di
alvaro tracey sta qua alla scienza qui
altra roba vediamo un attimo madonna
saitama c'è saitama ma dove ok vediamo
quanto fatalità va beh va beh certo
saitama e fortissimo ho vinto
vabbè ho vinto saitama costa 100 ed è
incredibile one shot a vabbè vabbè
ragazzi sto provando a fare una roba un
po strana metto un miliardo di giganti
normali per vedere se riescono a tener
testa a ai giganti con gli speciali che
sono tutti lì davanti il problema è che
non penso che siano in grado di far
qualcosa di titan questi qua poi adesso
vediamo madonna che casino prova a
vedere perché sono abitanti secondo me
la mia il mio computer esplode però va
bene proviamo vediamo è un attimo una
battaglia un po unilaterale
è un agglomerato di salsicciotti non si
capisce niente
però so che dentro sti cosi ci sono i
nemici quindi probabilmente sta vincendo
noi non ne sono sicuro ma che si
uniscono fanno un gigante più grosso del
gigante con tale pacchetto tutti si sono
ammassati sul singolo gigante speciale
va bene ogni tanto quali si stanno
andando a suicida nell'oceano nel nome
la voglio perdere che scusate importante
vedere che si ammazzano tutti quanti è
il momento di cascare des otto sono
morti tutti c'è questo qualche rimasto
incastrato in un albero adesso è morto
va bene stanno credito il quale che ha
stamani servendo un gigante che stava
scappando va bene che alla fine non
hanno figli i miei non hanno fatto
niente
una schiera di mikasa del momento cento
mikasa versus tutti sti colossi non si
capisce o computer mi sta chiedendo
pietà perché sono capitato nelle grinfie
visto youtuber maledetto tra tutti gli
youtuber che esistono in sto cazzo di
pianeta proprio lui deve rompermi le
palle molti cani primer toque a robinho
però mi casa double data cioè 100 mica
sono le che fanno le usi è che fai te ne
privi bacheche fasto verso il colossale
dicono sarei fa un verso casa abbastanza
sta con cui tutto sto casino e ancora
quanto durerà il colossale ragazzi
veramente macello nessuna mi casa è
morta in questo video incredibile non ho
visto un cadavere di mika sa neanche a
pagarlo ma di giganti sì ecco il fatto
che assurdo non i che non ho frame non
solo non so c'è un amica s'aqua è orami
casa questa forse è morta una mikasa
potrebbe essere non capisco niente
cercando di capire se cercando di vedere
il gioco mi dà una mano a renderizzare
sicura un'amica già sicuro almeno un
amica sa è morta
va bene raga il mio computer mi sta per
implodere io lo so non saprei neanche
descrivere questa scena ma il gigante
colossale diventata una specie di
acquerello in mezzo a 800 mikasa ancora
vive che vogliono farli in culo così
quindi io potrei concludere quel video
tanto andrà a finire in un modo solo
signori spero che il video vi sia
piaciuto questo e rata con titan sul
totali a to write battel simulator n'è
valsa la pena
assolutamente
si faccia vivo più bello di totali
arcole ragazzi consensi che piacerà
tanto mi piace anche per il gigante
colossale in questo punto sta soffrendo
c'è non c'è iscrivetevi e come sempre ci
vediamo ad un prossimo video bella
ragazzi
[Musica]